[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video I
will be talking about one of my favorite
characters in the entire black clovers
series and that is saying a lot for a
series that features the likes of hasta
Yami Vanessa
Charmy meadow Leona and so many other
amazing characters I'm about to explain
the complete origins and backstory of
Zora eda Ali the nature and potential of
his ash trap magic and I will also
explain why I love Zora as a character
and why he is one of my absolute
favorites in the entire series if you
enjoyed the black clover content on this
channel and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell just a quick warning this video
will contain manga spoilers about Zora
and his life in particular so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned when we first meet Zora he
appears to be an emo ginger absolute mad
lad who doesn't respect or fear anyone
after witnessing purple orchid
vice-captain zerks Lochner mistreating
an elderly woman Zora takes him out
steals his magic night robe and pretends
to be him in the Royal magic knight
selection exam once he shows up to the
exam Zora
still using the name zerks pretends like
he doesn't care about anything and like
he is completely bored being there at
first he refuses to work together with
his teammates and he even seems to fall
asleep during the first match to the
great annoyance of his two teammates
hasta and mimosa
however the funny thing about Zoras
carefree attitude is that he is actually
the opposite of what he pretends to be
far from not caring about what happens
during the match
Zora is actually a meticulous planner
and we later learned that he spent all
of the night before carefully planting
his magical traps all over the exam
battlefield Zora possesses the ash trap
magic card which means that his magic
allows him to create and control ash and
he can use it to generate a wide variety
of magical traps Sora can make traps
that will bind their opponent in place
go off on contact like a landmine make
the
and fall through the ground as soon as
they step on it and more the more time
in Manos hora dedicates to setting a
trap the more powerful it can become and
one of his abilities is to create a
counter tribe that will reflect a magic
spell and throw it back at Sora's
opponent with doubled the power of the
original spell because it takes time for
Zora to set up his traps and especially
his more powerful traps the very nature
of his magic demands for him to be the
opposite of careless for his magic to be
effective he has to carefully plan out
his every move in his every spell so it
is ironic that he pretends to be bored
and carefree during the first match but
this attitude does also help to hide the
true nature of both his magic and his
personality from his potential opponents
Zora has trained extensively in order to
become fast strong and skilled in his
use of magic he scores a 3 out of 5 in
physical strength magic amount and magic
sensing a 4 out of 5 in magic control
and a perfect 5 out of 5 in both
cleverness and insight which speaks to
his exceptional intelligence when we
first meet Zora we also see him acting
very disrespectfully towards the magic
Knights he says he doesn't respect
anyone not even the wizard King and he
clearly isn't afraid of anyone either
not the wizard King not Yami and not
even Meryl Ilona
and you know that you're an absolute
freaking mad lad if you're not at least
a little bit terrified of the uncrowned
undefeated lioness but all those aura is
pretty fearless his feelings about the
magic Knights are again two complete
opposite of what he wants us to think at
first he pretends like he doesn't really
care about the magic Knights and that he
is only there to mock them but in
reality Zora was raised by his father
Zara who was the first peasant to become
a magic knight
Sora's father had great respect for the
magic knight title and he did his very
best to serve honorably and to help
those in need
Sora's father loved being a magic night
and he ingrained this love and respect
for this noble position within zora as
well even though he failed to pass the
magic Knight exam many times Sora's
father kept on trying until he finally
became a knight he was an extremely
cheerful person who loved to joke around
and pull
friendly pranks on Sora and more than
anything Sora's father always told his
son how much he loves being a magic
knight how much he loves helping those
in need
and how much he loves fighting alongside
other powerful and honorable magic
knights in this sense austin reminds or
of his father and this is one of the
reasons why sore eventually warms up to
hasta
Sora greatly admired his father and his
current appearance is actually based on
a doll that his father made for him back
when he was 12 a doll which his father
had named the emissary of justice super
mage Sora
unfortunately Sora's father Zahra was
killed in battle he had been a member of
the purple orcas squad and one day when
he was visiting his father's grave Zhora
overheard some other members of the
purple orcas talking about how Zara was
actually betrayed by his own squad
members apparently many of the magic
Knights in his own squad looked down on
Zara for being a peasant and for caring
too much about helping other peasants
and it appears that one of his fellow
magic Knights attacked Zara from behind
Zhora is absolutely devastated after
hearing this and his entire life is
shattered when he gets older
Sora makes it his mission to stand up to
corrupt magic knights who mistreat
others especially peasants he uses his
impressive magical and physical
abilities to fearless Lee take on
high-ranking magic Knights and teach
them a lesson but despite the fact that
zorad first claims to dislike all magic
Knights in reality he idealizes the
position of the magic knight he believes
that a true magic knight should be
exactly what his father believed a magic
knight was a brave selfless and
honorable fighter for justice who puts
his own life on the line to help other
people regardless of rank and social
status Sora's problem is with the
corrupt magic Knights who abused their
position and mistreat those who are less
powerful than them and he has a problem
with these corrupt magic Knights not
because he hates the whole idea of magic
Knights but precisely because he
respects the magic knight title so
greatly and because of this he is
furious when he sees magic Knights who
are not living up to that
szura's view of the magic nights is
actually very similar to stains view of
perot heroes just like stained believes
that being a pro hero is a noble calling
that must not be sullied with corruption
and self-interest
Zhora believes that the magic nights are
meant to protect and help all people
that they're supposed to be noble and
honorable heroes and that everyone who
would abuse their position as a magic
knight deserves to be punished the
difference between zorah and stain is
that stain is far too extreme he is
willing to actually kill the pro heroes
that he deems unworthy and he doesn't
only attack heroes whom he catches in
the act of doing something corrupt or
immoral stain is even willing to kill
someone like tensei eda someone who
isn't a bad person but just doesn't fit
into stains rigid definition of a true
bro hero by contrast Zora only goes
after those magic knights whom he
witnesses doing corrupt and immoral
things and he doesn't outright kill them
he merely teaches them an important life
lesson that they won't soon forget
just like his last name suggests Zora
ideale is an idealist he believes that
all magic knights need to live up to the
noble position that they hold and this
mindset was ingrained in Zora from a
very young age due to the influence of
his father but Zora doesn't go to the
same extremes as stain and he doesn't
become a villain at some point during
his travels sora meets Yami captain of
the black bulls like with pretty much
every other misfit Yami offers Zora a
place in the black bolts and Zora
eventually accepts his place as a black
bull magic knight proving once again
that he doesn't really hate or lack
respect for magic Knights he simply
expects them to behave like the heroes
they are supposed to be and whenever he
sees a magic knight acting in a way that
is not worthy of the magic Knight title
Zora isn't afraid to call them out on it
as he does to Finn Rahl's brother
languorous I love Zora as a character
because he's an eccentric and quirky guy
that is a ton of fun to watch he is an
emo ginger mad lad who doesn't take [ __ ]
from anyone and you can't help but like
the guy but what makes Zora one of my
absolute favorite characters in black
clover is not his cool character design
his intriguing magical ability or his
eccentric carefree
those things are all interesting but
beyond that Zhora is also a deep
character with a tragic and yet
heartwarming backstory and a sense of
righteous outrage that drives his
actions
Zora believes in justice for all he
believes that anyone who is prepared to
put their life on the line in order to
help others should have the opportunity
to become a magic night and he cannot
stomach the fact that some magic Knights
are willing to sully their own noble
title by behaving in corrupt and immoral
ways Zora is not just an emo ginger mad
lad he is a relatable fearless and
inspirational emo ginger mad lad with a
heart of gold I absolutely love his
interactions with Aastha throughout the
series and I can't wait to see even more
of Zoras amazing antics in the future
let me know what you guys think who is
your favorite character in black clover
and do you agree with me that Zora is up
there is one of the greatest characters
in the series let me know down in the
comments I'd love to hear from you if
you enjoyed this video you want to see
more you can leave a like to let me know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell if you'd like to
support more content on the channel
and get some epic anime merch check out
our online store anime out Broadcom we
have original designs that were done
exclusively for us by pro manga artist
Cuusoo mati including this dream big
work hard hasta shirt for your fan of
the channel feel free to use the
discount code uproar 25 at checkout for
an instant 25% off and a huge thank you
to all our anime upper patrons for
supporting our work when I especially
thank our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh and Keylong and also
our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all other clans including
infused silver Maddie Mac 239 a lowland
Adam and Ace 17 FF DP if you guys feel
that our content provides value for you
and you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
uproar patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]